Se nos ha dicho en la clase de álgebra, que
si tenemos una línea, ésta tendrá una razón
constante de cambio de "y" con respecto a "x".
Es decir, que nuestra línea tendrá una inclinación
constante y la inclinación o pendiente...
pendiente...
se define como el cambio en "y"...
este triangulito es la letra griega delta
y se usa para expresar cambio,
el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x" y si tratamos con una línea esto es constante...
esto va a ser constante... constante...
para una línea recta... una línea... para una línea.
Lo que quiero hacer en este video es demostrar
esto usando triángulos similares,
pongamos 2 grupos de dos puntos.
Aquí va el primer grupo de dos puntos
y ¿cuál es nuestro cambio en "x"
entre estos dos puntos?
Bueno, aquí lo vamos a poner en el eje "x",
estos son los puntos sobre el eje "x",
por lo que nuestro cambio en "x"es este,
¿y cuál es nuestro cambio en "y"?
Bueno, ahora vamos a ver esos puntos sobre el eje "y"
y éste que también lo puedo poner
acá es el cambio en "y".
Ahora pongamos el otro grupo de dos puntos,
aquí abajo y hagamos lo mismo que en el anterior.
Vamos a marcar los valores de cada punto en
el eje "x" y en el eje "y",
entonces aquí están en el eje "x" que el cambio en "x"
lo voy a expresar por conveniencia aquí abajo
y el cambio "y", aquí está en el eje "y"
y este cambio en "y" lo voy a dibujar acá.
Lo que les quiero mostrar es que elegí estos
puntos aleatorios y este cambio en "y" de
arriba, con respecto al cambio en "x", tiene
la misma proporción que el cambio en "y"
aquí abajo con respecto al cambio en "x"
y esto lo haré usando la similitud.
Y una vez que demuestre que estos triángulos
son similares, todos quedará demostrado.
Recordemos lo que significa ser similar.
La similitud se cumple si y solo si se tienen
ángulos correspondientes iguales entre los triángulos...
ángulos correspondientes... congruentes...
Aún con diferentes tamaños en los lados
estos triángulos son similares,
pues los ángulos correspondientes
son congruentes o iguales.
Aquí voy a dibujar dos triangulitos...
aquí en diferente posición...
éste más o menos así...
vamos a ponerle los valores a los ángulos...
y aún con diferentes tamaños en los lados,
esos triángulos son similares pues los ángulos
correspondientes son congruentes o iguales.
Lo genial de los triángulos similares es que una vez que establecemos que dos triángulos lo son,
entonces la proporción entre los lados del triángulo, también serán congruentes o iguales.
Es decir, que la proporción de este lado
con respecto a este otro lado,
va ser igual a la proporción de este lado, de este otro
triángulo, con respecto a este otro lado,
de manera que pueden ver porque esto nos será
útil para la demostración que queremos hacer,
ya que si estos triángulos son similares
entonces la proporción entre sus lados correspondientes será igual
y como estos son puntos arbitrarios, la demostración servirá para cualquier grupo de puntos en la línea.
Tratemos de demostrar la similitud.
Lo primero que sabemos es que son triángulos
rectángulos, estas líneas verdes que estoy
dibujando son horizontales, así que estas
dos van a formar líneas paralelas,
ambas son horizontales, y esta línea
naranja es la transversal.
De manera que si tenemos líneas paralelas
y una transversal que las atraviesa
podemos decir que estos dos ángulos van a ser iguales.
De manera similar vamos a extender estas líneas
verticales de mis diferencias en "y" en ambos
triángulos y son líneas paralelas, ambas
son perfectamente verticales
y de nueva cuenta nuestra línea naranja va a ser la transversal, entonces si tenemos una línea transversal
que intersecta dos paralelas, los ángulos
que se forman con estas lineas van a ser iguales
y ya habíamos dicho que son
triángulos rectángulos así que,
este ángulo de aquí, es un ángulo recto
es de 90 grados y es igual.
Entonces acabamos de demostrar que estos triángulos
tienen exactamente los mismos ángulos internos.
Por lo tanto ambos triángulos son similares,
ahora, si ponemos las etiquetas a los lados de ambos triángulos, aquí pongo "a", aquí "b", aquí "c" y aquí "d",
podemos afirmar que "a" entre "b",
es igual a la proporción entre "c" y "d",
debido a que son triángulos similares.
Dicha proporción es la definición de pendiente,
en cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x".
Así que este será constante a lo largo de
nuestra línea, pues estos fueron puntos aleatorios.
Y con esto queda demostrado lo que queríamos.